in another battle with Congress a House
committee has voted to hold two members
of the president's cabinet in contempt
over a plan to add a citizenship
question to the 2020 census can you
imagine you send out a census and you're
not allowed to say whether or not a
person's an American citizen the
president is claiming executive
privilege to keep Congress from seeing
documents related to the decision Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy what
comes next well this is an issue that is
going all the way to the Supreme Court
Michelle later this month the justices
are expected to rule on whether the
citizenship question can be added to the
2020 census White House says they're
just going back to something that has
been asked at various points in the past
but Democrats see politics at work here
and so they have been trying for a year
to try to get their hands on memos and
emails that would show who got the
question added and why but the Justice
and Commerce Department's won't give
them what they want and so the House
Oversight Committee voted yesterday to
hold the leaders of those agencies in
contempt of Congress which could give
the committee's more power to subpoena
these documents Nancy people actually
have a choice whether to answer a
question on the census so why does this
actually matter
well because experts have warned that if
you add a citizenship question it is
going to discourage some number of
immigrant families from answering the
census and so they say that's going to
skew population figures and because
these numbers are used to determine
everything from school funding to
congressional districts Democrats worry
that the immigrant heavy areas that they
often represent are going to end up
suffering as a result they think that's
the real reason this question is being
added Nancy thank you man is he quarters
at the Capitol